[Music]
brought to you by the every dooll app
start budgeting for free today Dylan is
with us in Miami hi Dylan welcome to the
Ramsey
Show hey guys thanks for having me um I
am 22 years old and I just graduated
undergrad and got married the next day
my wife and I don't have any debt but um
two weeks after our wedding my mother
passed away oh no gosh I'm sorry Dylan
was that unexpected so uh yes and no uh
yes and the fact that she declined so
quickly um she died at 61 so she left us
um her Ira which has about 300,000 in it
and then the main reason I'm calling is
because um the house that she left has
$60,000 left on it and I'm just
wondering should I what I'm planning to
do is rent it out and have my renter pay
the mortgage but I also have the life
insurance which is I got about 990,000
left on that just kind of sitting in my
bank account should I just go ahead and
pay the mortgage off completely and then
have uh that passive income or uh what
would you guys to wow I'm so sorry
that's
completely tough two weeks after you're
married to make all these decisions I
wish we could I wish we could slow down
okay MH here's the thoughts that pop
into my head okay number one uh renting
a property as a landlord is not passive
income that's humorous uh that's crap
from Tik Tock okay uh because there's
nothing passive about dealing with
renters I've got a bunch of them uh I
have been I am planning to hire a
property man doesn't matter it's not
passive this is very active you you have
a hassle factor in your life called
renter okay it's just part of and
they'll be renting your mom's home too
and they're goingon to be in the home
you probably grew up in right right yeah
yeah that's weird emotionally it's hard
okay so that that's number one thing so
so
um can this be done yes it can be done
uh you're 22 you're brand new
married in my opinion the last thing you
need is the hassle of a rental
property um but if you're going to keep
this and give that a
try uh you should pay it
off okay okay and uh because that will
lower the hassle you won't have a
payment anyway and so take the take the
insurance money out of the checking
account pay the mortgage off I normally
wouldn't like to make that decision on
that property that quickly but I will
tell you like the current the rate the
home Rachel grew up in is now in my
rental portfolio we kept it it is weird
I haven't lived in that house in 20
years it is weird to go over to that
house with other people's crap in it
still emotionally and I'm I landlord a
bunch of property and I grew up in the
real estate business so I've got a huge
advantage over you and I'm old I've done
this a lot okay you're 22 this is your
first property I'm warning you that the
first time that
they screw around with the house you
grew up up in they being the tenant uh
it's going to be emotional for you just
be ready for that okay no one is it's
never going to be the same it's never
going to smell the same in there okay uh
and so all of that now so if you want to
get a professional property manager
that's great uh are you local Dylan
where the house is are you guys
close I'm not I'm about I'm in Miami the
house is in Central Florida that's not
too bad I I I I don't like long-distance
landlording either so I I'm going to
tell you that it it with all the
emotions if we had a little bit of time
to digest all of this I might just sell
it but that's even a harsher thing than
letting a renter be in it so I it's not
an automatic thing that a 22 years old
two weeks after you're married you ought
to be a
landlord that's not an automatic thing
okay so it's an automatic thing you
probably shouldn't do actually uh just
in terms of quality of life for you but
it's thrown in your lap and here we are
so if you want to try it just be
forewarned that this is not it's not
passive uh you're going to have some
emotions around other people and smells
being in your house no pets I love pets
one of my favorite things on the planet
is my little dog but no pets not in my
rental properties okay we call them
$10,000 cats they devalue your house
$10,000 when they put the cat in there
okay and so sorry that's the way that
works so I'm tell this experienced land
talk for you Dylan for you and your wife
where are you guys at financially I know
you said you have no debt um you
obviously have this
$300,000 Ira from your mom uh are you do
you and your wife do you all rent do you
own a home where are you guys at yeah
we're renting we're we're just kind of
getting started financially our combined
income is probably around 70 or
80 okay I would sell this house and buy
you a house I know how much is the how
much would the house how much is the
house worth do you know
right now it's probably worth 250 maybe
300 tops I would sell this house and buy
you a house and when I say that out loud
two weeks after you got married your mom
dies that's very harsh for me to say
that yeah it's hard for you to even hear
that and think about that but 5 years
from today you having this is a rental
property versus you and your new wife
having a new home to live in that that's
a much better wiser
decision and um I you know I I know I'm
asking a lot for you to process of a lot
of emotions and you don't have to make
this decision today Dylan and you don't
have to do it because I should do it but
you know give yourself some time and
kind of just you know maybe you try the
renting thing for a year and I would
still pay it off and maybe you look up
in a year and you and your wife are like
man we want to get settled somewhere you
have a great asset that your mom left
you which is such a gift and you can use
that gift to continue her like I say I
mean that what a beautiful thing that
she you know has for you guys so um
maybe it's not right now but maybe you
look up in 6 months and think okay we
can make we can make this decision but
for you and your family now going
forward you and your wife um you can
really use this to jump start you guys
if this house had no emotion T to it if
it was if she had it as a rental
property right you would have sold it
already in your mind you would you would
I'm going to be buy me and my bride a
new house you wouldn't be going I'm
going to rent and keep this as a and let
me say this this may not be Dylan's case
real quick but the idea of having real
estate it's a big deal it's a big deal
people want a rental prop I mean the
idea you want to have a rental property
two hours away and be renting yourself
yeah no I agree but I'm just saying I
know Dylan I mean I if I can get into a
22-year-old's head what the the kind of
content that's out there and what people
are saying about about for sure will
tell you you got to have the rental
house yeah but it's a very appealing
thing right to have this quote unquote
active income not passive but yeah so so
there's a I I I get where you're at but
I think what you have to realize is when
you set you and your wife up really well
then in 10 years you could get into this
if you wants you want y yeah and you'll
be a millionaire yeah and you'll have a
paid for home for you and your new bride
the the impact on your marriage is
positive the impact on your health is
positive um the impact on your finances
is positive I just and I'm sorry sorry
you're having to make these decisions
but that's what I would do if I woke up
in your shoes sir this is the Ramsey
Show